first of all I want to tell you my
thoughts and my analysis of what
happened yesterday with fomc
uh they hiked 25 basis points as all the
market anticipated so no surprises here
now at that point Bitcoin didn't really
even move because that 25 basis points
was already priced in with this drop at
the start of the week so Bitcoin didn't
move okay then the fomc statement
nothing new uh in fact as my friend I'm
Jake he said
it's a copy pasta from the previous ones
okay it's a copy and paste that is
statement from the previous ones pretty
much okay nothing new variable in both
the press conference in my opinion was
very interesting I think that you don't
power was in fact quite dovish
why for two reasons the first reason is
that he said that the FED staff are not
forecasting are recession anymore
that means that according to the fed the
idea of the recession is out the window
it's gone there is not going to be a
recession that's what they are saying
but
do I trust this
no I don't why well it's not because I
believe that I know more than them of
course not they know more than me but
according to all you know all the data
that we have the lady indicator below
the
deals are inverted uh tell me a time
in history
but we had all of this data that there
was no recession
because I don't think I'm gonna be able
to send me one case okay
um that's one thing also in 2008
this fed chairman Bernanke I think he
was
Bernanke
I think it was yeah he said
in 2008 okay guys
he said we are not forecasting a
recession
what happened in 2008
well we had one of the worst economic
crisis all right so
these words what he said yesterday is
exactly the same and what happened in
2008 so why should I believe him
there is no credibility guys
that's what I think that's my opinion
again we'll see what happens of course
they know more than me
I'm not saying I'm I'm right and they're
wrong of course no we'll see what
happens but uh it's difficult to believe
because uh if I look back
in history with all this data
I cannot tell you any single
time that there was no rotation with all
this information okay so that's what I
think and also reminds me again what
happened in 2008 is this literally the
same words from the Fed
and then they had economic crisis in
2008 okay
then
the other reason why I think he was
quite dovish is because he he didn't say
that there was going to be another hike
for sure okay
in my opinion we'll see what happens but
in my opinion it's very likely that this
was the last hike okay now remember that
in August there is no an influency
meeting okay the half the month off then
in September
what the market is projecting
okay they are projecting that in
September they post and in October they
hike so we're gonna wait we wanna see
all this data coming out but
uh now 27th of July I think that they
hiking cycle has finished here we'll see
what happens okay
um this doesn't necessarily mean that
I'm bullish in the long term because it
also if you check out the data after
they start cutting rates okay no pulsing
rates but after they start cutting rates
which I think will be between December
uh February
all right of next year
once this targeting rates then that's
usually when our session plays out
because the hiking cycle all the
consequences and effects of the hiking
cycle comes with some delay and usually
matches with when they start cutting
rates okay so that's what I think
from the fomc and because in my opinion
because he said that the FED is now
forecasting artificial anymore Market
pumped okay check this out but this is a
projection that I drew a few minutes ago
before starting the video when I was
watching the chart okay this is my
projection but if you check here let me
remove the second
I'll show it again okay uh Wednesday at
six here this is there for MC so you
have this couple of candles nothing is
happening then you have the press
conference finishing price shoots up
okay what if it is there is not going to
be a recession and now it is stabilizing
here all right now why do what do I
think it's going to happen here well
what I think is that if you notice here
you got here the a weekend range the
markets for you
okay
so do you hear some kind of weekend
range then you go here a false move
okay and then if you notice from Monday
the trend has been going up so why do I
think is what happened next okay I think
that there might be a reversal coming
into play today all right we'll see what
happens
now if there is a reversal
because we've been you know creeping up
the whole week
usually the reversal plays towards the
previous weekend range so that will be
to the upside okay but in this case
because the trend from Monday has been
going up I think that the reversal
should be to the downside
okay now if you notice here but this is
kind of like a train line that I marked
because usually below these 10 lines
there is a lot of liquidity okay imagine
how many stop losses there are here from
traders that have longed here here here
here here this one here below the train
and it's full of stop losses okay that's
why
today
I have uh drawn this projection we'll
see if it plays out or not in this
production what I'm looking for is that
they retrace this liquidity pool
okay entirely
so this would be the top
three market for you okay because if you
notice we don't have much left
it's something like this really left of
liquidity pool all right and that will
take you to around 29 760. also if you
go into the four hours time frame
what do you see here guys
I've been talking out to the guys that
are currently in the course of July
um we were talking about this week
I'm always saying that this week needs
to get filled okay now at this point is
not filled I think the 50 comes around
this one over here
so it's likely that either right before
the New York session or right at the
start of finishing we might see a stop
hunt
and then a reversal okay that's what I'm
aiming or projecting for today's price
action so
um 50 of the week is around here at
least that has to get filterable because
we have the liquidity pool in the one
hours time frame I would like to see I
even a new high to be honest okay
practice High deviate here and then drop
okay lose this trend line and then
continue dropping so that's what I want
to see in in Bitcoin today to to be able
to trade it essentially
uh now let me go back here so you can
see the projection in case you want to
see it again might be wrong
for today also
um another Confluence let's go into the
four hours time frame guys
where are we
let me remove this
okay if you notice we are right below
the range lows okay yesterday
there was a week we try to come back
above the range
failed to do that okay now price is when
I try to make an attempt because it has
to fill the 50 of the week so let's see
what happens okay if we start to see
for our candles closing above the range
again then
the idea of going lower at least between
today and tomorrow should have been
validated okay that's what I think uh
because that would probably tell you
that there is going to be maybe another
deviation here and the name to the
mid-range football
again at this point I'm going to tell
you the same as yesterday I'm still
favoring lower prices to be honest okay
that's what I see at the moment
is exactly
this projection
over here okay
if something like this what I see for
Bitcoin now when can you show this
should you short hair the liquidity pool
I think that's risk okay I think that a
good thing would be when you see
the 50 of the week in the on the four
hour time frame getting felt and then
you see another candle closing below the
range lows okay and then losing also
this red line that's when you can show
because you've basically confirmed that
price cannot get back above the range
again and we've lost this trend line all
right so that's when price can continue
going lower
okay where to well if we go to High
block capital
let me guide you there here we are you
can see that there is a bunch of
liquidity between 28 800 and 28 700 okay
and if you notice here the more
Southwest we go here the more liquidity
that gets built here why because the
retail Trader is open in Longs okay
that's what the market maker wants in
order to increase the liquidity here so
when they bring price lower and hit
these liquidations they're gonna hit
even more liquidations
that they had previously so the move is
going to be even more efficient okay
that's what I'm aiming between 28 800 28
700 should be taken next so yes anyway I
don't think I have much more to say okay
that's what I think uh from yesterday's
fomc that's my opinion about Jordan Paul
saying that there are no forecasting a
recession
that's what I think that this could also
be a potential last a hike and this
could finish the hiking cycle okay
again that's only my opinion we'll see
what happens uh later on in the future
and this is the projection that I have
for today okay
Phil
the 50 of this week in the four hour
time frame that we're almost there okay
potentially you could even get to the
hundred percent or sweep the highs
because eventually then you'll be
filling this liquidity pool over here
I cannot draw
straight lines okay that one there
all right the liquid pool over there and
then you want to basically see price
coming lower
rejecting off from this
uh white but white line 29 500 losing
this train line and then they are set to
go lower okay and hit this on so that's
what I'm aiming for between today and
tomorrow again if we start to see price
closing above the range lows again
then the story is gonna change because
then this could tell you that okay that
might be a potential deviation the same
as we had here okay so do you want to
see consolidation here and then another
leg higher to the mid-range so that's
pretty much everything guys
thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you soon